auch digital politische sprecherin der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion johanna quartal
bei uns frau konnte
wäre es ihnen persönlich lieber gewesen
denn auf dem parteitag schon über die
spitzenkandidatur entschieden worden
wäre natürlich in ihrem sinne
sozusagen als beteiligte an diesem
möglicherweise jetzt spitzenduo wir
hatten ja die mitgliederbefragung und
die war echt ein deutlich dass sie
mitglieder gesagt haben sie wollen
selber entscheiden und dann steht das
der mitglieder natürlich zu dass sie das
auch dass ich mich entscheiden dürfen
klar was mir persönlich lieber gewesen
ich hätte das schon hinter mir
aber das mitgliedervotum zählt und dem
inzwischen sich tatsächlich entschieden
worden ist sollen zwei seien die jetzt
in einer urwahl aller mitglieder
bestimmt werden stehen sie denn in jedem
fall zur verfügung bei dieser wahl
führen
auch bei der befahrung online er gut das
heißt das wird jetzt in den nächsten
vier bis sechs wochen der fall sein dann
werden wir sehen
rechnen sie damit dass sie sich auch mit
unterstützung von jörg nolte da
durchsetzen können ich gehe davon aus
dass ich gute chancen habe ja ich habe
für rücken wenn eine partei den spieler
viele leute die mir die daumen drücken
die für mich wählen werden und dann
lassen wir das auf uns zukommt kaum war
die zeitung junge freiheit
veröffentlicht dass sie damit im spiel
sind waren sie auch schon ersten
anfeindungen ausgesetzt
einer ihrer bundestagskollegen jürgen
pohl habt gepostet ironisch er sei auch
gefragt worden
sozusagen um auch ihre bereitschaft eine
frage zu stellen stört sie dass das
gerade das friendly fire aus der eigenen
richtung kommt das hat mich am anfang
ein bisschen getroffen gebe ich offen zu
hat das was in meiner familie rum
gewählt worden ist um zu gucken ob da
irgendwelche leichen verwundet sind
mittlerweile lache ich darüber bin ich
ganz ehrlich dass da steht man drüber
das gehört anscheinend zur politik und
da muss man durch
ich hab es gab schon angesprochen in dem
zusammenhang sind da auch diese hinweise
zu verstehen auf ihren bruder der ein
digital unter
immer ist das ist da eine zu große nähe
durch sie als digital politische
sprecherin der fraktion gebe also sie
kann er sich aussuchen die gerüchte
gehen einmal ich bin eine mittellose
feng shui beraterin die das
bundestagsmandat wie unbedingt nötig hat
oder aber ich bin jemand der millionen
und von meinem bruder oder von mark
zuckerberg persönlich bekommt um im
nicht federführenden digital ausschluss
tatsächlich einfluss zu nehmen als fdp
politikerin auf weltkonzerne das ist so
lächerlich das kann man gar nicht ernst
nehmen also da ist nichts dann vermuten
sie die quelle dieser kampagne dieser
persönlichen nähe zu ihrem also dieser
nicht persönlichen sondern sozusagen
politischen oder ökonomischen nähe zu
ihrem bruder vermuten sieht die quelle
dieser kampagne in der eigenen partei
nein also das was ich bis jetzt gelesen
aber aus facebook kommt sie tatsächlich
von ex mitgliedern kommen wir ganz kurz
zu dem was sie möglicherweise als
spitzenkandidatin besonders
beschäftigten wie die politischen
inhalte der afg sie dann zur
bundestagswahl und im wahlkampf antritt
da ist ja gestern sozusagen der claim
bekannt gegeben worden in deutschland
aber normal kann man denn eigentlich
wirklich so genau definieren was normal
ist ist dass deutschland vor 50 jahren
nein ich glaube dass sie noch gar nicht
auf der welt war in die normalität haft
ich glaube die normalität ist das wonach
wir uns im moment alle sehnen das leben
ist nicht mehr normal dadurch bewohner
ist es nicht mehr normal aber auch im
normalen alltag vor krone hat man
manchmal das gefühl dass das
irgendwelche grenzen verschwinden dass
das was man noch vor als normal
angesehen hat plötzlich völlig irre ist
das konservativ was für vollkommen
normal war plötzlich irgendwie
rechtsradikal sein soll
also wir meinen dass normale wonach sich
der normale bürger sieht und der normale
bürger steht morgens aufgeht zur arbeit
arbeitet dort hat seine familie zu hause
hat das häuschen im grünen das ist der
größte traum
das ist normales leben und dass es nicht
langweilig sondern das ist eigentlich
wirklich dass und darf sich die meisten
sehen und natürlich die menschheit ja
solange sie gibt immer fortentwickelt
die erde dreht sich jeden tag braucht
die afg nicht auch ein gerüttelt maß an
modernität zb mehr aufmerksamkeit für
den klimaschutz
nein wir haben das genau gegenteil wir
stellen den green deal den blue deal
gegenüber dass wir sagen wir wollen
tatsächlich innovativ nach vorne gehen
mit deutschland wir möchten die
technologie in deutschland stärken
wir möchten
dass die schüler mehr in den
mint-fächern ausgebildet werden dass wir
gut gebildete kinder wieder haben dass
bildung wichtiger ist als gender gaga
das ist uns wichtig wir möchten
tatsächlich in digitalisierung
investieren wir möchten den
quantencomputer investieren das ist das
was du schon nach vorne wir müssen
deutschland zukunftsfähig machen was
machen wir mit dem blut und dem setzen
wir tatsächlich diese klimastudien ging
jetzt wird ja niemandem verboten zum
beispiel ein traditionelles familienbild
zu pflegen oder auch eine traditionelle
familie zu gründen also mutter vater
kinder aber muss das unbedingt ein
leitbild sein
naja das ist nun mal so
es ist die kernfamilie das ist vater
mutter kind das ist das normale leben
eigentlich natürlich gibt es also auch
an sind die anders leben aber das
normale leben ist nun mal vater
das meinte ich ja gerade leitbild heißt
ja ich leite lass mich leiten von meinen
überzeugungen von meiner
selbstbestimmung von meiner eigenen
verantwortung das kann das traditionelle
familienbild sein das kann aber auch
etwas ganz anderes sein im zusammenleben
der menschen aber wir sehen nun mal die
familie wirklich als kern der
gesellschaft aus der gehen die kinder
hervor und die kinder sind nun mal
unsere zukunft aber gehen sie da ein
bisschen an der gesellschaftlichen
realität in deutschland vorbei nein ich
sage ja nicht dass alles andere mich
geben darf natürlich gibt es nebenbei
ganz andere lebensgewohnheiten an
partnerschaften die auch vollkommen in
ordnung sind
das heißt sie sind schon der meinung
dass es auch andere werte gibt die man
leben kann die in dieser gesellschaft
auf platz habe er selbstverständlich und
werde von niemandem seine werte
verbieten da hat aber der
parteivorsitzende vorhin wörtlich gesagt
seiner rede wer unsere werte nicht
teilen das ist ein feind der demokratie
sind dass sie schneller ich denke mal
das spiel ja auch wirklich grundlegende
werte in deutschland an
also wenn man was sie sich die
gleichberechtigung zwischen mann und
frau nicht mehr respektiert wenn man
hier parallelgesellschaften aufbaut und
wirklich die die ursprünglichen werte in
deutschland nicht akzeptiert das ist
aber was anderes als wenn man sagt es
ist völlig normal dass es auch
gleichgeschlechtliche partnerschaften
wie sehen sie die gefahr dass die afg
mit ihrem wahlprogramm dass wir dann
auch als spitzenkandidatin vertreten
müssen möglicherweise die gesellschaft
spaltet moment ja sowieso in einer
schwierigen situation ist nein ich
glaube es genau geht das gegenteil der
fall wenn wir sehen die unnormal das
leben geworden ist und wie sehr sich die
menschen nach normalität sehen und wir
bieten ihnen diese normalität wir bieten
ihnen das an was sie sich festhalten
können in dieser schwierigen zeit da
glaube ich passiert genau das gegenteil
wir spalten nicht lernen da die chance
wir ein bisschen die gesellschaft wieder
zusammenzubringen aber sie glauben dass
das wahlprogramm der afg an der art
brückentechnologie ist in ein besseres
leben im busch denke tatsächlich wenn
wir uns den begehungen überlegen was
zählt welche werte zählen für uns
was ist uns wichtig das finden wir alles
in unserem wahlprogramm und wenn wir da
aufhören einfach mal gegeneinander
zeiten sonst auf bildung zu lassen
sondern man wirklich nur etwa das wir
angehen dann wird man sehen auch das ist
vollkommen normal
ja da ist aber zum beispiel jemand der
sie unterstützt wir haben in vielen
fragen völlig anderer meinung als björn
herr kennen und beide sind ja mitglied
dieser partei und repräsentieren auch
die afg im wahlkampf gehören höckel muss
ja auch noch einen landtagswahlkampf in
thüringen am gleichen tag bestehen aber
wir haben wir schließen jetzt hier ein
wahlprogramm dieses wahlprogramm ist für
uns alle hinter das müssen wir uns
stellen das müssen wir vertreten
das gilt für einen vergehen thüringen
genauso für einen leuten in ganz
deutschland soweit johanna portal im
phoenix-interview möglicherweise eine
der beiden spitzenkandidaten
kandidatinnen für die afg im
bundestagswahlkampf danke dass sie dabei